On me demande souvent quelle est la différence entre mon travail
et celui des planificateurs typiques de stratégie à long terme du Pentagone.
Et la réponse que j'aime donner est,
que typiquement, ils imaginent le futur des guerres
dans le contexte de la guerre.
Et ce que je fais depuis 15 ans dans ce milieu --
et ça m'a pris 14 ans pour m'en rendre compte --
c'est que j'imagine le futur des guerres dans le contexte de tout ce qu'il y a autour.
Alors j'ai tendance à me spécialiser dans l'espace entre la guerre et la paix.
Ce que je vais vous montrer est une idée pour un livre.
Enfin, beaucoup d'idées.
C'est celle qui me pousse aujourd'hui à voyager autour du monde,
et à interagir un peu avec les militaires étrangers.
Ce que je vais vous montrer a été produit pendant les deux ans où j'ai travaillé
pour le Ministère de la Défense,
réfléchissant à une nouvelle grande stratégie nationale
pour les États-Unis.
Je vais vous présenter un problème
et je vais essayer de vous apporter une réponse.
Voici mon concept idiot favori datant des années 1990 au Pentagone,
la théorie des stratégies asymétriques d'anti-accès et d'aires non autorisées.
Pourquoi est-ce que ça s'appelle comme ça ?
Peut-être parce qu'il y a tous ces 'A' alignés.
C'est du charabia pour dire que,
si les États-Unis entrent en guerre avec quelqu'un, nous allons être grands,
et ils vont être petits.
Et s'ils essaient de nous combattre d'une façon traditionnelle, de manière directe,
nous allons leur botter les fesses,
c'est pourquoi les gens ne s'y risquent même plus.
J'ai rencontré le dernier général de l'Air Force qui a réellement
abattu un avion ennemi au combat.
Il est désormais général une étoile.
Voilà à quel point on est loin de rencontrer une force aérienne
qui voudrait nous combattre.
Alors cette surcapacité est génératrice de problèmes --
la Maison Blanche les appelle des succès catastrophiques.
(Rires)
Et nous essayons de résoudre ce problème,
parce que c'est une capacité incroyable.
La question est : qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de bien avec ?
D'accord ?
La théorie des stratégies asymétriques d'anti-accès et d'aires non autorisées --
un charabia que l'on vend au Congrès,
parce que si nous leur disons juste que nous pouvons botter les fesses de quiconque,
ils ne nous achèteraient pas tout le matériel que nous voulons.
Alors on leur dit : stratégies asymétriques d'anti-accès et d'aires non autorisées,
et leurs yeux deviennent vitreux.
(Rires)
Et ils nous disent, allez-vous en construire dans ma région ?
(Applaudissements)
C'est ma parodie, et ce n'en est pas vraiment une.
Parlons d'un espace de conflits,
par exemple, la crise du détroit de Taïwan de 2025.
Parlons d'un ennemi localisé dans cette zone de conflits.
Disons, le Million Man Swim.
(Rires)
Les États-Unis doivent avoir accès à cet espace instantanément.
Ils lancent des stratégies asymétriques d'anti-accès et d'aires non autorisées.
Une peau de banane sur le macadam.
(Rires)
Des chevaux de Troie sur nos réseaux informatiques
révèlent nos talons d'Achille immédiatement.
On dit, la Chine, c'est à vous.
L'approche de Prométhée, principalement une définition géographique,
est focalisée presque essentiellement sur le commencement d'un conflit.
On fait jouer la première moitié de l'équipe dans une ligue
qui insiste pour conserver le score jusqu'à la fin du jeu.
C'est le problème.
On peut augmenter notre score contre n'importe qui,
et après se faire botter les fesses dans la seconde partie --
ce qu'ils appellent la guerre de quatrième génération.
Au lieu de cela, voici la façon dont j'aime la décrire.
Il n'existe pas d'espace de conflits auquel l'armée américaine ne peut accéder.
Ils ont dit qu'on ne pouvait pas faire l'Afghanistan, on l'a fait sans problème.
Ils ont dit qu'on ne pouvait pas faire l'Irak.
On l'a fait avec 150 blessés au combat en six semaines.
On l'a fait si rapidement qu'on n'était même pas préparé à leur effondrement.
Il n'y a personne qu'on ne peut faire tomber.
La question est : que faire de ce pouvoir ?
Donc il n'y a aucun problème pour accéder aux zones de conflits.
La chose à laquelle nous avons du mal à accéder, c'est la zone de transition
qui doit suivre naturellement,
et l'instauration de la zone de paix qui nous permet d'avancer.
Le problème est que le Département de la Défense ici
vous en fait voir de toutes les couleurs.
Le Département des Affaires Étrangères, ici, dit :
« Vas-y mon garçon, je sais que tu peux le faire. »
Et le pays se retrouve au bord du précipice,
il fait comme dans les dessins animés, puis il tombe.
(Rires)
Ce n'est pas un problème de force écrasante, mais de force proportionnelle.
C'est une histoire de technologies non-mortelles,
parce que si vous tirez à balles réelles sur une foule
de femmes et d'enfants en émeute
vous allez perdre des amis très rapidement.
Ce n'est pas un problème de propulsion du pouvoir, mais plutôt de stabilisation,
ce qui qui ramène à la légitimité avec les locaux.
À qui avez-vous accès dans cet espace de transition ?
Vous devez créer des partenaires internes, vous devez avoir accès à des partenaires de coalition.
Nous avons demandé 17 000 gardiens de la paix aux Indiens.
Je connais leurs dirigeants, ils voulaient nous l'accorder.
Mais ils nous ont dit, vous savez quoi ?
Dans cette zone de transition, vous êtes des fiers-à-bras.
Nous ne pensons pas que vous réussirez,
nous n'allons pas vous donner nos 17 000 gardiens de la paix pour faire du remplissage.
Nous en avons demandé aux Russes 40 000.
Ils ont dit non.
J'étais en Chine, en août, et j'ai dit :
« Vous devriez avoir 50 000 gardiens de la paix en Irak »
« C'est votre pétrole, pas le nôtre. »
Ce qui est vrai, c'est leur pétrole.
Et les Chinois m'ont répondu : « Dr.Barnett, vous avez parfaitement raison.
Dans un monde parfait, nous en aurions 50 000 là-bas.
Mais ce n'est pas un monde parfait,
et votre gouvernement ne nous en rapproche même pas. »
Mais nous avons du mal à mesurer les conséquences de nos actes.
Nous avons eu de la chance, honnêtement, au niveau de la sélection.
Nous rencontrons différents opposants parmi ces trois-là.
Et il est temps d'admettre
que vous ne pouvez pas demander au même gamin de 19 ans de tout faire, jour et nuit.
C'est sacrément trop difficile.
Nous avons une capacité sans pareil à faire la guerre.
Mais nous ne sommes pas très bons pour le reste.
Honnêtement, on est meilleur que n'importe qui, et on est toujours nul pour ça.
Nous avons un brillant Ministre de la Guerre.
Nous n'avons pas de Ministre de Tout le Reste.
Si c'était le cas, ce type serait devant le Sénat,
il serait encore en train de témoigner sur la prison d'Abu Ghraib.
Le problème, c'est qu'il n'existe pas.
Il n'y a pas de Ministre de Tout le Reste.
Je pense que nous avons une capacité inégalée à faire la guerre.
J'appelle ça la Force Léviathan.
Nous devons construire une Force de Tout le Reste,
ce que j'appelle les Administrateurs du Système.
Je pense que cela représente vraiment
le manque d'une réglementation de A à Z pour le monde entier
pour traiter des états en faillite politique.
Nous en avons une pour traiter les états en faillite économique.
C'est le plan de faillite souveraine du FMI, d'accord ?
On en débat à chaque fois qu'on l'utilise.
L'Argentine est passée par là, en violant beaucoup de règles.
Ils s'en sont sortis à la fin, et nous avons dit, ne vous inquiétez pas.
Il est clair qu'un certain niveau de certitude
donne le sentiment d'un résultat non nul.
Nous n'avons rien pour traiter les états en faillite politique,
que franchement, tout le monde aimerait voir partir.
Comme Saddam, Mugabe, Kim Jong-Il --
des gens qui tuent par centaines de milliers ou par millions.
Comme les 250 000 morts au Soudain à l'heure actuelle.
À quoi ressemblerait un système conçu de A à Z ?
Je vais faire une différence entre ce que j'appelle
la moitié avant, et la moitié arrière.
Et appelons cette ligne rouge, je ne sais pas... mission accomplie.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Ce dont nous disposons en ce moment,
au commencement de ce système, c'est du Conseil de Sécurité de l'ONU.
Que peuvent-ils faire ?
Ils peuvent mettre vos fesses en accusation.
Ils peuvent en débattre, ils peuvent l'écrire sur un morceau de papier,
ils peuvent mettre ça dans une enveloppe et vous l'envoyer.
Et ensuite dire en termes non équivoques : s'il vous plaît, arrêtez-ça.
(Rires)
Ça vous donne environ quatre millions de morts en Afrique centrale au cours des années 1990.
Ça vous donne 250 000 morts au Soudan au cours des 15 derniers mois.
Chacun doit répondre à ses petits-enfants un jour ou l'autre,
sur ce qu'il a fait pour lutter contre l'holocauste en Afrique.
Et vous feriez mieux d'avoir une réponse.
Nous n'avons rien pour traduire cette volonté en action.
Ce que nous avons, c'est la Force Léviathan américaine, qui dit :
« Vous voulez que j'abatte ce type ? Je le ferai.
Je le ferai mardi. Ça vous en coûtera 20 milliards de dollars. »
(Rires)
Mais voici le contrat.
Dès que je ne trouve plus personne pour faire le ménage,
je quitte immédiatement les lieux.
Ça s'appelle la Doctrine Powell.
Tout en bas, nous avons le Tribunal Pénal International.
Ils aiment les juger, ils ont Milosevic en ce moment.
Qu'est-ce qui nous manque ?
Une fonction exécutive qui traduira la volonté en action.
Parce qu'on n'en a pas,
à chaque fois que nous menons ces efforts,
nous devons nous défiler devant cette menace imminente.
Nous n'avons pas fait face à une menace imminente depuis
la crise des missiles de Cuba, en 1962.
Mais nous utilisons ce langage d'une ère révolue
pour nous intimider et nous obliger à faire quelque chose
parce que nous sommes une démocratie, et ça va avec.
Et si ça ne marche pas, on crie : « Il a un flingue ! »
juste au moment où on lui bondit dessus.
(Rires)
Ensuite on examine le corps
et on trouve un truc comme un vieux briquet, et on dit :
« Mince, il faisait sombre. »
(Rires)
Vous voulez le faire en France ?
La France dit : « Non, mais j'aime vous critiquer après les faits. »
Ce dont nous avons besoin en aval, c'est d'une grande puissance d'action,
ce que j'appelle la Sys Admin Force.
Nous aurions dû avoir 250 000 troupes réparties en Irak
sur les talons de ce Léviathan ratissant en direction de Baghdad.
Qu'est-ce que vous obtenez ensuite ?
Pas de pillages, pas de disparition de militaires,
ni d'armes, ni de munitions,
pas de Muqtada al-Sadr -- je lui démolis les os --
pas d'insurrections.
Parlez à quiconque qui était là-bas les six premiers mois.
Nous avions six mois pour remplir le contrat, pour finir le travail,
et on a tourné en rond pendant six mois.
Et ils se sont retournés contre nous.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'ils en ont eu marre.
Ils ont vu ce qu'on a fait à Saddam.
Ils ont dit : « Vous êtes si puissants que vous pouvez ressusciter ce pays.
Vous êtes l'Amérique. »
Nous avons besoin d'un fond international pour la reconstruction.
Sebastian Mallaby, du Whashington Post, a eu une bonne idée.
Prendre exemple sur le FMI.
Au lieu de collecter des dons à chaque fois, d'accord ?
Où allons-nous trouver ce type ? Au G20, c'est facile.
Regardez leur programme depuis le 11 septembre.
Tout est dominé par la sécurité.
Ils vont décider à l'avance comment l'argent sera dépensé.
Exactement comme au FMI.
Vous votez en fonction de la somme d'argent que vous investissez dans la cagnotte.
Voici mon défi pour le Département à la Défense.
Vous devez construire cette force, vous devez ensemencer cette force,
vous devez chercher les partenaires de coalition, créer un registre de succès.
Vous aurez ce modèle.
Vous me dites que c'est trop difficile à réaliser.
J'irai jusqu'au bout de cette série en six épisodes sur les Balkans.
On l'a fait de cette manière.
Je parle de régulariser ça, de le rendre transparent.
Vous voulez que Mugabe s'en aille ?
Vous voulez que Kim Jong-Il, qui a tué quelques deux millions de personnes,
vous voulez qu'il parte ?
Vous voulez un meilleur système ?
C'est pourquoi c'est important pour les militaires.
Ils connaissent une crise d'identité depuis la fin de la guerre froide.
Je ne parle de la différence entre réalité et désir,
même si je peux le faire parce que je ne suis pas dans l'enceinte de Washington D.C.
(Rires)
Prenez les années 1990.
Le mur de Berlin s'effondre, on fait Tempête du Désert.
La division commence à surgir entre les militaires
qui voient un futur dans lequel ils peuvent vivre,
et ceux qui voient une futur qui commence à leur faire peur.
Comme la communauté des sous-mariniers américains,
qui regarde la marine soviétique disparaître du jour au lendemain.
Ah !
(Rires)
Ils commencent donc à passer de la réalité au désir
et ils créent leur propre langage
pour décrire leur voyage de découverte intérieure.
(Rires)
Le problème c'est qu'il vous faut un grand adversaire sexy à combattre.
Et si vous n'en trouvez pas, vous devez en créer un.
La Chine, en croissance, tu feras l'affaire !
(Rires)
Le reste de l'armée a été trainée dans la boue
au cours des années 1990.
Ils ont développé ce terme très dérisoire pour décrire ça :
les opérations militaires autres que la guerre.
D'après vous, qui rejoint l'armée pour faire autre chose que la guerre ?
En fait, la plupart.
Jessica Lynch n'avait jamais prévu de riposter.
La plupart d'entre eux ne tiennent pas de fusil.
Je maintiens que c'est un code dans l'armée
pour dire : nous ne voulons pas faire ça.
Ils ont passé les années 1990 à travailler dans les endroits compliqués
dans des parties mondialisées du monde.
Ce que j'appelle le noyau et la brèche.
L'administration Clinton n'était pas intéressée par ça.
Pendant huit ans, après avoir foiré les relations dès le premier jour,
le jour de l'inauguration des gays dans l'armée,
ce qui était habile.
(Rires)
Nous étions donc seuls pendant huit ans.
Et qu'avons-nous fait, seuls, chez nous ?
On a acheté une armée et on en a dirigé une autre.
C'est comme le type qui va chez son médecin et lui dit :
« Docteur, ça fait mal quand je fais ça. »
(Rires)
Le médecin répond : « Arrêtez de faire ça, imbécile. »
J'avais l'habitude de donner ces instructions au Pentagone au début des années 1990.
Je disais : « Vous achetez une armée et vous en dirigez une autre.
Et au final ça va faire mal, c'est mal.
Méchant Pentagone, méchant ! »
(Rires)
Et ils me disaient : « Dr Barnett, vous avez tout à fait raison.
Pouvez-vous revenir l'année prochaine et nous le rappeler ? »
(Rires)
Certains pensent que le 11 septembre a guéri ces fissures,
que ça a secoué les gourous de la transformation à long terme
du haut de leur grande vue sur l'histoire,
que ça les a trainé dans la boue et qu'ils ont dit : vous voulez un adversaire interconnecté ?
J'en ai un, il est partout, allez le trouver.
Et ça élève les MOOTW -- comme on prononce cet acronyme --
du rang de foutaises au statut de grande stratégie,
parce que c'est comme ça que vous allez réduire cette brèche.
Certains mettent ces deux choses ensemble
et ils appellent ça l'empire, ce que je trouve crétin comme concept.
L'empire ne concerne pas seulement l'application d'un minimum de règles,
ce que vous ne pouvez pas faire,
mais l'application d'un maximum de règles, ce que vous devez faire.
Ce n'est pas notre façon de gouverner.
Ça n'a jamais été notre façon d'agir sur le monde extérieur.
Je préfère l'expression Administration du Système.
Nous imposons l'ensemble minimum de règles
pour rester connectés à l'économie mondiale.
Il y a des mauvaises choses que vous ne pouvez pas faire.
Comment cela influence-t-il notre façon de penser le futur de la guerre ?
C'est un concept qui fait qu'on me calomnie au Pentagone.
Ça me rend aussi très célèbre.
Tout le monde a un avis.
Retournons au début de l'histoire de notre pays --
historiquement, la défense signifiait la protection de la patrie.
La sécurité signifie tout le reste.
Inscrites dans notre constitution,
deux forces différentes, deux fonctions différentes.
Levez une armée si besoin,
et maintenez une marine de guerre pour la connectivité au jour le jour.
Un Département de la Guerre, un Département de Tout le Reste.
Un gros bâton, une matraque.
Un instrument de domination,
une force de rassemblement.
En 1947, nous avons fusionné ces deux choses ensemble
au sein du Département de la Défense.
Notre raisonnement à long terme devient :
nous sommes à couteaux tirés avec les soviétiques.
Attaquer l'Amérique, c'est risquer de faire sauter le monde entier.
Nous avons relié la sécurité nationale à la sécurité internationale
en à peu près sept minutes de temps.
Ce n'est plus notre problème à présent.
Ils peuvent tuer trois millions de personnes à Chicago demain,
et on ne ripostera pas avec l'arme nucléaire.
C'est l'aspect effrayant.
La question est : comment reconnecter la sécurité américaine
avec la sécurité mondiale pour rendre le monde bien plus agréable,
et pour sceller et contextualiser l'emploi de la force
dans le monde ?
Ce qui est arrivé depuis, c'est la bifurcation que j'ai décrite.
Nous avons parlé de ça
dès la fin de la guerre froide.
Créons un Département de la Guerre, et un Département d'Autre Chose.
Certains disent que le 11 septembre l'a fait pour nous.
Maintenant nous avons un match à domicile et un à l'extérieur.
(Rires)
Le Département de la Sécurité intérieure est une mesure stratégique pour nous sentir bien.
Ce sera le Département de l'Agriculture pour le 21ème siècle.
L'Agence de Sécurité des Transports (TSA) : des milliers qui restent sur place.
(Rires)
J'ai soutenu la guerre en Irak.
C'était un méchant avec de multiples antécédents.
Ça n'est pas comme si nous devions le retrouver,
en tuant réellement quelqu'un pour l'arrêter.
Je savais qu'on botterait des fesses à la guerre avec la Force Léviathan.
Je savais que nous aurions du mal avec la suite.
Mais je sais que cette structure ne change pas avant d'avoir rencontré l'échec.
Qu'est-ce que j'entends par ces deux forces différentes ?
C'est la Force de Hobbes.
J'adore cette force, je ne veux pas la voir partir,
en plus des armes nucléaires, ça élimine les grosses guerres.
C'est l'armée que le reste du monde veut nous faire construire.
C'est pourquoi je voyage dans le monde pour parler aux armées étrangères.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Ça veut dire que vous devez cesser de prétendre
que vous avez ces deux compétences disparates chez le même gamin de 19 ans.
Passer de l'une à l'autre du matin à l'après-midi, au soir,
matin, après-midi, soir.
Porter assistance, riposter,
porter assistance, riposter.
C'est trop.
Les gamins de 19 ans se lassent de ces oscillations, non ?
(Rires)
Cette force à gauche, vous pouvez entraîner un gamin de 19 ans pour faire ça.
Pour cette force à droite, il vous faut plutôt un flic de 40 ans.
Vous avez besoin de l'expérience.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire en termes d'opérations ?
La règle sera la suivante.
La force des Admin Sys est celle qui ne rentre jamais à la maison,
elle fait le gros du travail pour vous.
Vous libérez la Force Léviathan seulement de temps à autres.
Mais c'est la promesse que vous faites à la nation américaine,
à votre propre peuple, au monde.
Vous libérez cette Force Léviathan,
et vous promettez, vous garantissez que vous allez faire preuve,
immédiatement, d'une force des Admin Sys dans la foulée.
Ne planifiez pas la guerre si vous ne planifiez pas de gagner la paix.
(Applaudissements)
Une autre différence avec le Léviathan,
les partenaires traditionnels ressemblent tous aux Britanniques
et à leurs anciennes colonies.
(Rires)
Y compris nous, je vous rappelle.
Le reste dispose d'une plus grande variété de partenaires.
Les organisations internationales, les ONG,
les organismes bénévoles privés, les entrepreneurs.
Vous n'y échapperez pas.
La Force Léviathan, ce ne sont que des opérations conjointes entre les sections militaires.
On en a fini avec ça.
Ce qu'il nous faut, ce sont des opérations inter-agences,
ce qui était, franchement, le travail de Condi Rice.
Et je suis surpris que personne ne lui ait posé cette question quand elle a été nommée.
J'appelle la Force Léviathan l'armée de papa.
Je les aime jeunes, mâles, célibataires, légèrement énervés.
(Rires)
J'appelle la Force des Admin Sys l'armée de maman.
C'est tout ce que l'armée masculine déteste.
Bien plus mixte, plus âgée, cultivée, mariée avec des enfants.
La force à gauche : en action ou elle dégage.
La force à droite : toujours présente.
La force à gauche respecte les restrictions du Posse Comitatus
sur l'utilisation de la force aux États-Unis.
La force à droite va l'effacer.
C'est ce que deviendra la Garde nationale.
La force à gauche n'entre jamais dans le champ de compétence
du Tribunal Pénal International.
Mais la Force des Admin Sys en fait partie.
Des définitions différentes de réseaux centraux.
L'une détruit les réseaux, l'autre en crée.
Et vous devez faire la guerre ici de façon à faciliter ça.
Avons-nous besoin d'un plus gros budget ?
Avons-nous besoin d'une conscription pour y arriver ?
Pas du tout.
Les gens de la Revolution of Military Affairs m'ont dit pendant des années
qu'on pouvait le faire plus rapidement, moins cher, plus petit, et aussi mortel.
J'ai dit : « Super. Je vais prendre le budget des Admin Sys de votre poche. »
Voici ce qui est important.
Vous allez d'abord construire la Force des Admin Sys au sein de l'armée américaine.
Mais en fin de compte vous allez y mettre des civils, probablement deux tiers.
Travailler en inter-agences, l'internationaliser.
Donc oui, ça commence avec le Pentagone,
mais avec le temps ça va franchir cette rivière.
(Rires)
Je suis allé au sommet de la montagne, je peux voir le futur.
Je ne vivrais peut-être pas suffisamment longtemps pour vous y amener, mais ça va arriver.
Nous aurons un Département de Tout le Reste
entre la guerre et la paix.
Dernière diapo.
Qui obtient la garde des enfants ?
C'est le moment où les Marines dans l'assistance se crispent.
(Rires)
Et c'est le moment où ils pensent à me faire la peau
après l'intervention.
(Rires)
Lisez Max Boon.
C'est l'histoire des Marines -- petites guerres, petites armes.
Les Marines sont comme mon West Highland Terrier.
Ils se lèvent tous les matins, ils veulent creuser un trou
et ils veulent tuer quelque chose.
(Rires)
Je ne veux pas que mes Marines portent assistance,
je veux qu'ils se comportent en Marines.
C'est ce qui empêche la Force des Admin Sys d'être une force faiblarde.
Ça l'empêche d'être l'ONU.
Si vous tirez sur ces gens, les Marines viennent et vous tuent.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Le Département de la Marine, les sous-marins stratégiques vont par là,
les bâtiments de combat de surface vont là-bas,
et la nouvelle est qu'ils peuvent en fait être aussi petits.
(Rires)
Je l'appelle la Navy des Poussières Intelligentes.
Je dis aux jeunes officiers : vous commanderez peut-être 500 vaisseaux dans votre carrière,
la mauvaise nouvelle est qu'ils risquent d'être vides.
Les porte-avions vont des deux côtés parce qu'ils sont un atout stratégique.
Vous verrez la configuration -- l'aéroporté, comme les porte-avions.
Les blindés vont ici.
Voici le vilain secret de l'Air Force,
vous pouvez gagner en bombardant.
Mais vous avez besoin de beaucoup de ces types sur le terrain pour gagner la paix.
Shinseki avait raison à ce propos.
L'Air Force, le transport stratégique aérien vont des deux côtés.
Les bombardiers, les avions de chasse, vont ici.
Le Commandement des Opérations Spéciales descend à Tampa.
les tireurs vont par là.
Les Affaires Civiles, cet enfant bâtard, va ici.
Retour à l'Armée.
En ce qui concerne les tireurs et le Commandement des Opérations Spéciales.
Pas de répit, ces gars sont toujours en activité.
Ils débarquent, font leur boulot, et disparaissent.
Tu me vois maintenant, n'en parle pas après.
(Rires)
Je n'étais jamais là.
Le monde est mon terrain de jeu.
(Rires)
Je veux que les tireurs gardent la gâchette facile.
Je veux que les règles soient aussi flottantes que possible.
Parce que lorsque les choses sont entravées à Chicago
avec les trois millions de morts
ça pervertit notre système politique au-delà de l'imaginable,
ce sont eux qui les tueront en premier.
Donc c'est mieux de les laisser faire quelques erreurs en route,
au lieu de voir ça.
La réserve --
Les réservistes de la Garde nationale sont pour les Admin Sys.
Comment les amener à travailler pour cette force ?
La plupart des pompiers le font gratuitement.
Ce n'est pas une question d'argent.
C'est une question de monter au front avec ces gars et ces filles.
Dernier point, la communauté du renseignement --
les muscles et les agences de défense vont par là.
Ce que devrait être la CIA, ouverte, raisonnée, open source,
devrait venir ici.
Les renseignements dont vous avez besoin pour ça ne sont pas secrets.
Ça n'est pas secret.
Lisez ce grand article du New Yorker
sur la façon dont nos jeunes, de 19 à 25 ans, en Irak,
enseignent entre eux la manière de faire fonctionner les Admin Sys,
avec Internet en salles de chat.
Ils disent : « Al Qaeda pourrait nous écouter. »
Ils disent « Eh bien, ils connaissent déjà ces trucs. »
(Rires)
Prenez un cadeau dans la main gauche.
Ce sont les lunettes de soleil qui ne font pas peur aux gens, un truc simple.
Les censeurs et la transparence, les frais généraux vont dans les deux directions.
Merci.